>>Rishi Chandra: Another cool feature that
I wanted to also highlight was actually taking
the same principle that Vic already mentioned
earlier today about taking the mobile version
of the Android Market and being able to push
applications directly to your phone.
To, actually, do this demo I would like to
bring up Brittany Bohnet, a member of the
Google TV team, to help out.
[ Applause ]
>>Brittany Bohnet: Okay. I am just going to
log in here real quick.
>>Rishi Chandra: Okay.
>>Brittany Bohnet: Looks like we are logged
in.
>>Rishi Chandra: We are logged in? Okay.
>>Brittany Bohnet: Yep.
>>Rishi Chandra: Let's go ahead and pull it
up.
Like Vic showed you earlier today, you can
take the mobile version of Android Market
and push it to other phones but you can also
push it to other Android devices. In this
case you will see on the right we have Google
TV. Actually, just see which box we are on.
Assuming we are on the second box now, Vincent?
>>Vincent Dureau: Uh-huh.
>>Rishi Chandra: So we might have to switch
that, Brittany, to the other. Try other TV.
Just scroll over it and make sure it's on
the second one. All right. Let's try this.
We have differing TVs connected so we will
do this in real time.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the Twitter
app.
All right.
So here, actually -- why don't we go back.
I think it's the other TV if you go to the
top right.
>>Brittany Bohnet: Okay.
>>Rishi Chandra: So the second one. Where
it says "other TV."
That's my code name for box 2.
[ Laughter ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Not much -- All right. So
why don't we go ahead and try to download
that. While we are doing that, Vincent is
actually showing the list of applications
installed. So go ahead and click it and see.
Give it a few seconds. We are going to have
to check if this is the right box or not.
We might not be -- oh, there it is. All right.
Good.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Whew.
And now we can open up the app directly from
Google TV, and again, it will just work.